check out sponsors nature's blend they
specialize in premium with European
black seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sun now the website is in the
description link below the souls of the
animals before saying we don't believe
it's I don't think we live we believe do
they have souls yes or the source that
ours no because we have free will so for
example you have the Angels you have the
humans and you have the animals yeah the
animals do react based on angels do as
they total they have no free will what
we believe makes us different and unique
is that we are bad we can be better than
the angels or worse than animals if we
act on our desires I want this I want I
it was a different animal and what does
the same thing if you want to be better
than the Angels then you obey God based
on it's not because you have no free
will and you force to like the angel but
because you want to so with us
animals are different they don't have a
free will so in that context animals
have great right you can't abuse an
animal we have hadith from their things
there was a woman who helps you the
prostitute medicine but she helped the
dog like in
and so if you're standing and it's not
that there's a difference opinion where
says okay cut the fault while still is
so this can be if we're living in times
of where certain things are okay just
because they made okay doesn't mean
[Music]
there's many reasons oh we look I care
achter who he was look at what he came
down with all of their stuff that is
common we observe this character the
revelation that has come with I was
given to him the predictions that he
made so all of this is we don't find any
flaws in their question is okay what
else P is he a man for example if it was
a man who was a liar the pagan Arabs
offered America we'll give you money
we'll give you woman
okay no it wouldn't see that's the thing
that's good that's good that's that's
why stammers yeah we don't believe in
divinity belongs to anyone except God
Almighty so the thing is that miracles
are done via the permission of God you
know prophet comes in says oh he goes
that's a miracle it's done with the
permission of God this is where
Christians went astray because they will
see Jesus to a miracle a miracle
that's quote sees God it must be good
but we're saying well Moses party to see
different prophets in different miracles
but why is that Jesus all of a sudden so
that's where we say that miracles for
example we believe the biggest miracle
is a Koran is live in America where you
can analyze it you can see do you get it
if it's not from God you'll find errors
contradictions so the Koran is itself
but with a quick and easy artistic oh
yes that's so firstly from an Arabic
speaking person you're not gonna be able
to meet the challenge of bringing
something like well of course of course
of course
as long as if it's absolutely blind
faith that's wrong but if this question
has been answered I love them a being
answered and the same elements where
this is actually like if you know
everything about God you know God you
know if God knows everything and you
wanna know there was a difference so
there's things that you should know
but someone comes in says he has faith
faith faith faith is there nothing to
hear it but it's time says no but Allah
says his plan in kissimmee well are we
did I feel anyone
there are signs for those yeah there are
signs for those who know he does need to
be here to know his power is require I
have to be here to here we say he can do
that without being here without being
here he can you can say you know what
like everything anything that the most
small attic is away he doesn't need to
be I have to mean what is I have to be
here to heels conversation what we're
saying is that yeah but but we're saying
he doesn't require if we say he needs to
be everywhere here's everything that I'm
gonna say for example in Toyota is the
good in toilet but you explain
it's like we don't believe okay this day
put there so we just say we believe the
way we praise him and glorify Him is to
acknowledge that he's aware everything
but he's not in the creation from Zeke's
butterfingers like what would I say is
is that we should come to a common
agreement where the truth is so I would
say does God need to be everywhere to
know things just have different kinds of
need to be in the creation that's what
we see with sweetie is the creation the
creation is be in the finite there was
no beginning and there was no end there
was no so what we're seeing is that he's
not because give rise to something so
how can it be a part of something
however there is for example zero zero
one zero give rise to one can zero zero
then there is certain modes even zero
I'm trying to say in my my person use I
think Maps is aware if you must describe
in nature but also the way nature
functions and works I think is the only
universe because when you that's what
troops in infinite can never be fine
in Finland doesn't exist in the real
world in my vicinity but juicy infants
well we are day folks so this is a real
concept already was still technically a
movie if you know not really because if
you take away from information infinite
matter if you have to infinity so if
infinite has no beginning or end you can
add or take away for me so we believe so
the thing is with your saying I would
believe God is eternal there is nothing
like and he cannot be finite because it
goes against his own time you have
finite subsets of that time which is we
can't equate our reality to cause
reality that we live in time God is
bound to times I think you guys to us to
masses because ice makes them more
sensitive of course yellow just finding
things is not really this yeah so the
thing is this restriction is so but the
thing is is like mathematics is used we
see at the water in the universe it
helps us to understand here it
understands us to show the magnificence
of oxygen and then we say God is so
magnificent is eternal that I cannot be
with in his creation change
that's good
any questions comment you come down the
difference in you're more handsome this
is how we have discussions nicely
without seats provide humanity you know
learning from each other mathematics
like next time